5070 TI it's about as fast as a 4080
sometimes a 4080 super it costs 50 bucks
less technically than the 470 TI it's
not going to be available the real price
is almost $1,000 it's not worth it all
right so this is going to be an
interesting review today um I'm not
going to actually talk a whole lot about
the performance of the card I got our
charts we're going to show you that
we're going to give the tldrs we're
going to talk about the actual drama
that's happening with this card not
because drama sells but because this one
is like just
unabashedly like bad I don't know how
else to explain
it the XG 2736 and the XG 2536 gaming
monitors from vonic feature 240 HZ
default refresh rates 1 millisecond
response time mode and industry-leading
0.5 millisecond moving picture response
time modes that are ideal for gamers
demanding a Competitive Edge designed
with Esports in mind these XG monitors
feature fully adjustable and low profile
footprint stand for optimal viewing
distance that professional G gam demand
to learn more about the XG 27361 1440p
and XG 2536 1080p Competitive Gaming
panels for vsonic follow the link in the
description below I'm going to try and
get through the actual performance
review within the first 5 minutes of
this video and then we're going to talk
about everything else so I'm obviously
talking about the RTX 570 TI uh which
MSRP embargos lifted today you're going
to see a lot of varying satisfaction
amongst reviewers when it comes to this
card because there are depending
depending on who you asks who who you
ask there are two very different prices
associated with this card we will finish
with that we are going to just get to
the the nuts and bolts and then the
facts which are the nuts and bolts and
the performance and then we'll talk
about everything else because all that
performance means nothing until you
correlate price price is the third
triangulation data point that makes any
of those other numbers matter for
instance if it had crap performance and
it gave you mediocre you know gaming in
1080P or whatever and it cost 20 bucks
okay that's a good value if it gave you
gaming performance at 20 bucks if it
gives you okay performance at
$11,000 that's a whole different story
spoiler alert these 570 TI are costing a
grand moving on uh so I mean we're going
to talk about performance power draw
temperature generational performance
uplift all the normal outline stuff that
I've kind of come up with with our
revamped testing style obviously once
again huge thanks to GN for helping us
revamp our lab which has literally been
going non-stop for a month so you'll
notice that our charts have grown
they're going to continue to grow we're
going to go all the way back to 20
series to make sure that we've got as
much data that we can make it relevant
for people that are looking to upgrade
if they're a generation 2 three or four
old okay so key specs it's got 8,960
caor on the GB 203 or Blackwell
obviously uh 4070 TI respectively has
7680 caor and then 370 TI has 6140 caor
so that's the generational uplift that
we're talking about I only did the
calculations between 470 and 570 we know
370 to 4070 is like 80% across the board
once Nvidia got off or back on tsmc and
off the &m uh process that Samsung had
performance came uh up quite a bit RT
cores are running on the fourth gen RT
core there's 70 of them 60 RT cores
which are third gen found in the 470 TI
and 48 RT cores found in the 370 TI uh
which are second gen so any of our tests
that use RT that's where you'll see the
newer cards really kind of shine
specifically because the there's more RT
Cor and they're faster smarter can do
the math quicker RT cores so that's how
that works tensor cores again there's
more of them 280 in the 570 TI which are
fifth gen tensor cores versus fourth gen
240 cores found in the 470 TI and 192 of
them found in the 370 TI which are third
gen cores 16 GB of gddr 7 no gddr 7x
this time around which is kind of
interesting almost every family launch
has had X I'd expected it on the 5090
and 5080 didn't exist so maybe is no X
variant this time around uh apparently X
not going to give it to you uh 256bit
bus uh PCI Gen 5 obviously for an
effective 896 gab per second of
bandwidth uh base clock 2300 boost clock
2452 I didn't do a a frequency chart on
this one um it boosts right up to about
2800 MHz depending on the model keep in
mind this is the Asus Prime supposed to
be an MSRP model it's not no matter what
Nvidia or anyone says it's not an MSRP
model we'll talk about that today um
there is no Founders Edition card for
this particular 70 TI there was also not
a Founders Edition card for the 4070 TI
there was however a Founders Edition
card for the 30 series cards so you're
going to see a good maybe 2 or 3%
variance depending on the model that you
look at this is not the OC model um OC
models tend to have anywhere between
like 50 to maybe 100 MHz additional
boost clock um depending on the cool
design so you're going to see a lot of
variance depending on the models that
you're looking at on how robust the
cooler is what the overall temperatures
are the power limits they they all have
their different kind of secret sauces
baked in based on the aib that you buy
from so our tests are run specifically
at stock power limit which is 300 wat
TDP and well supposed to be on this card
this card actually goes a little higher
we'll talk about that today so even
though it's a supposed to be like a
reference is style which is what the
prime kind of is now you'll notice Prime
has been around for Asus on the
motherboard side for a long time
denoting it's more of an entry-level
product it's now available on the GPU
side unfortunately this is an
entry-level product that really wants
premium pricing and we'll talk about
that again in a second so this probably
does have a slightly uplifted um TDP on
this unfortunately because a card is
sent by Nvidia and not Asus I don't have
a deck specifically for this card so I
don't know what its base TDP is supposed
to be I guess GPU Z could have probably
told me but I don't care about that I
care about what's actually being drawn
through the cable which is what we
measured uh okay gaming performance you
know what let's just we'll put the
charts on the screen like we typically
do pause the ones you want to look at I
can tell you right now across the board
either lands just under a 4080 just
above a 4080 and under a 4080 super and
sometimes beats a 4080 super it really
is just mingling with the 4080 crowd
beating the 470 TI super across the
board as it was expected so
realistically it's a 4070 TI super super
or 4070 TI super TI super or a
4070 Platinum I don't know what I don't
know what to call it anymore maybe we
have a more precious metal now that
Nvidia can slide in there since they
like to put four graphics cards now in
between a family of of graphics cards um
I mean it does perform right around a
4080 480 super which at the time was a
$1,200 card or a $999 card which never
really existed at those prices very
often but the fact that it trades blows
with those cards it's not anything
terrible to write home about it has a
$749 MSRP which is $50 less than the 470
TI's MSRP of $799 but we all know those
prices are artificial they don't truly
exist really at least not for the last
several Generations because supply has
significantly uh not kept up with demand
and that's by Design Nvidia has
intentionally kept uh the amount of
inventory out in the market specifically
with 40 series low they kind of learned
from their lesson with 30 series where
they had too much 309s and 38 80s and 30
and 3080 TI in the in the wild so there
was a huge overlap of inventory with
previous gen with New Gen making New Gen
not worth really buying this time they
stopped producing months and months ago
on 40 series cards which means now
you're finding and I looked 4070 TI
today costing as much as $1,200 on the
used Market it is a complete show
um anyway moving on let's talk about the
percentage of performance uplift I
started talking about price but that's
another whole part of this video uh our
average generational uplift across our
gaming benchmarks not the synthetics is
21.46% that's that's kind of right in
the generational uplift we tend to see
anywhere between 20 to 25% the thing is
there's a couple of titles on here
pulling up that average because remember
my average is only among seven actual
gaming titles and two synthetics we
don't include the synthetics um
realistically it' be a little lower than
that so for instance cyberpunk gave me a
30.1% uplift in performance but our
cyberpunk test is specifically running
rate tracing medium at 4K actually let
me back up our previous generational
uplift we measured at 4K because they
were 80 and 90 tier cards 70 tier cards
i12 Sweet Spot 1440 even though this
card is very capable of 4K gaming in
most titles and you can see our titles
are like maxed out settings for the most
part to try and see what the worst case
performance would be like uh for the
card 1440p gaming however this card uh
can do absolutely no problem so my
generational uplift percentages are
based on 1440 this time not 4K so 30.1%
uplift in 1440 more than likely due to
the improved uh fifth gen uh or fourth
gen RT cores so there's more RT cores
it's a very heavy RT title and uh that's
kind of what cyberpunk is at this point
it is an RT Benchmark for the most part
but stalker 2 gave us a 16.3% uplift
Avatar 16.7 Horizon forbid West 15.8 so
you can see in these tests that are more
raster we are definitely seeing only
about 15 to 16 % performance uplift
generation from 470 TI to 570 TI
Borderlands 3 which is a heavy raster
test though where more Cuda cores the
better no RT or anything in that
25.6% and then F1 uh
20.8 and so I mean you can see you've
got the 20% in F1 the 24% in black myth
and the 30% in cyberpunk pulling up that
average but really it's more like a sub2
if we had more titles to test I think
that's why guys like Hardware unbox that
does like when they do like their 45
titles tested
that gives you a huge sampling to really
figure out what those averages are um so
definitely go check out the hardware
unbox guys if you haven't they
definitely not go the extra mile they go
the extra 10 kilm got to get the uh
measurements correct for for them I
don't think they use miles in Australia
but I could be wrong um temps 65° across
the board aftermarket cooler as you'd
expect didn't matter if it was furmark
didn't matter if it was cyberpunk it was
65° um the Fe card the 3070 TI actually
hits 80 but that's because this card is
a little bit I mean the 3070 TI is
doesn't have the greatest cooler design
um they really AED on the side of
Acoustics over thermals and again stock
fan curves so you can see the 3070 TI is
like way up there even though it is a
lower TDP card speaking of TDP though
this is where we started and I did
something a little different this time I
actually took our pmd2 measurement
device which is a inline power meter
that real time measures uh the power
going through the cable itself but I
also added the what the software is
reporting is being pulled from the PCI
Express lot if you recall we have an
issue right now with the pmd2 Riser
which is supposed to allow us to measure
PCI Express power draw um with the Gen 5
cards is giving us a problem even if we
switch to Gen 4 on the board so I just
took the software reading which to be
honest was 20 20 watts on the 4070 or
370 I believe it was but I just added
those to the PMD so you're seeing total
board power now there a difference
between Graphics power which is just
what the core is drawing or total board
power which is what everything is
drawing whether it be fans lighting vrms
memory all of that combined so the total
board power was actually pulling in firm
Mark over 320 Watts at times um bouncing
more or less between 3015 excuse me 315
and 320 so as you can see that is higher
than the 300 W TDP that the card is
advertised to be again could be because
the prime might have a slightly higher
Baseline TDP than what reference would
be but since we don't have a reference
card or an Fe card direct from the
manufacturer there's going to probably
be some variance in there again based on
the aib or AIC that you go with yeah and
also too that was in 4k uh the power
draw test we wanted to load the card up
as high as possible so again 4K furmark
or 4K cyberpunk um bouncing anywhere and
cyberpunk actually has lower dips see
furmark is a constant very difficult
fuzzy dnut to render so uh uh across the
board it's a much more solid line cuz
it's pegged against that power limiter
but in the cyberpunk depending on what's
being rendered on the scene things that
are particularly happening there's a lot
of variation in a game versus something
like a a stress test like the fuzzy
donut and firmar you'll see it bounce
about 25 watts between 300 and 325 not
terrible but is definitely a trend of
the 70 series cards getting more power
hungry too considering the fact that we
went from uh 290 up to 300 and as you
can see it's pulling more than 300 now
on this let's go ahead and talk about
the elephant in the room write your best
fat joke down below I might pin it
anyway moving on
price we showed on Twitter and I've got
a whole price chart on here we'll talk
about this in a second we showed on
Twitter that Micro Center put up its
pricing early and shows an available
date of February 20th that is the on
shelf date these review embargos today
they you're seeing on the 19th are
supposed to be for the MSRP models that
means the $750 price point however we
put a video up already that's actually
gone quite popular showing a $900 price
tag on this exact card
so I reached out to folks folks that are
also not allowed to give official public
statements from any company I'm about to
mention but I can tell you in video
specifically sent this card because
remember they don't make a Founders card
because it was an MSRP
model however what you're going to
notice today is there are folks that
were sent this card by
ASUS ASUS has communicated to their
direct seated reviewers we were seated
by Nvidia in the aibs can also send
their own models out to people if they
want typically the founders Edition card
would be the day early launch or the
Embargo lift or MSRP but it's almost
always Fe if it exists and then every
other card that costs more than that has
to wait till the next day it's the way
it's been since 30 series this same card
sent to other reviewers not by Nvidia
has to wait till the 20th because Asus
has communicated it is not an MSRP model
so to summarize the video I just put
live the other day that $900 is what
Microcenter is showing this pricing
is Micro Center does not lift the price
Micro Center is one of the few like
bastions where you can trust that they
are not going to increase the price they
sell them at the suggested retail price
given to them by the aibs in this
instance it's
$899.99 USD then I posted that reached
out to Nvidia and said WTF bro we were
told this is a $750 card we need to know
what the price really is that affects
everything regarding our review and we
were told it's a 750 C it's a 750 card I
don't know why Asus and Microcenter are
saying anything different it's a $750
card so then Microcenter updated its
pricing I'm assuming through pressure by
Nvidia cuz you'll notice that the $750
price is now there with the $88.99
scratched out however a couple hours
later the scratched out $899 is gone now
it just says $
749 but I posted all of this on Twitter
showing that the price changed none of
the other models did the msis the
gigabytes or any of the other cards they
still show $800 $939 $949 $9.99 ,09 they
all stay the same except this one card
so my question was did did Microcenter
make a boo boo was the price wrong or
whatever then I started getting some
anonymous messages and I had I I respect
the people that provided me this so I'm
not going to I'm they've asked me not to
share who they are I think for obvious
reasons cuz that's this is definitely a
big pot stir they they are a reviewer
that was sent the card by Asus and all
communication stated not an MSRP card so
what I think happened and I firmly
believe this now it was a speculation in
my price
video that the price sent to Microcenter
was the real price and the price told to
Nvidia was the paper price we suspect it
was never intended to launch at 750 and
by Microcenter putting up the pricing
early let the cat out of the bag
normally this is the kind of thing we
reviewers find out after the fact we
have when it goes live prior to on shelf
date we have to take the word of the
people we work with those words are
becoming less trustworthy because when
stuff like this happens there's three
people involved who do we trust we're
talking about Microcenter we're talking
about Asus or the aib a any brand and
that's who we have for this one so I
don't know what gigabyte has been
communicating or MSI has been
communicating or PN or gain word or any
other brands I only have this one to go
buy and Asus or nvidia's word the one I
trust the most out all three of those is
Microcenter okay I firmly believe
Microcenter is just showing the price
that's being communicated to them by
their vendor suppliers Nvidia I have a
feeling was under the assumption this is
a $750 card cuz that's what was sent to
them it's really a $900 card so that
actually makes this 20% above MSRP at
the $900 price point that is on
Microcenter but don't forget it now
shows 750 what we don't know because I
don't have a crystal ball to know the
future is what's going to happen on the
20th this video is being filmed
obviously prior to that and I'm curious
now if just to appease Nvidia the price
of 750 was communicated to Microcenter
but then on day one there's going to be
a switch flip back to
$900 that also the the amount of unfair
taking place for reviewers as well where
some of us were given this card and told
February 19th and others are told
February 20th presumably on the MSRP and
not MSRP Communications we are assuming
this card is $900 that is the most
believable thing uh that makes it the
most overpriced ridiculous thing there
is no one on this planet that should
consider buying a 5070 TI when it
encroaches on 4080 super pricing
unfortunately the 480 super pricing is
like $1,500 plus dollars right now so
you've kind of taken that whole price
bracket and just scooched it up a bit
they stayed separated but they just
everything scooched up and that's why I
talked about in my video this becoming a
rich person's hobby really pisses me off
so I did a little searching I went all
the way back to the GTX 470 so weird to
say that launched in
2010 15 years ago I have put together a
chart and we'll just put this on the
screen editing fill and just let it sit
on screen while I talk about this real
quick you will see two colors here you
will see blue which is the launch price
and you will see pink which is inflated
for 2020 or or corrected for 2025
inflation so we can see and put it in
correlation of what it would cost in
today's money back then okay so for
instance the GTX 470 launched at $349
with a corrected price of $58
the same year the 570 launch it was kind
of a late it was like it was like early
2010 and then late 2010 cuz that was
actually like the end of the era
technically anyway the 570 launched at$
3.49 and again the same corrected price
at 508 it was the same year so a whole
new tier of card for the same price okay
not at 349 that's where the 70 cards
should be that's where they belong not
the 60 series cards that was the gamer
card this 470 5070 6 can't even say it
470 570 670 were always
like you you know what I'm trying to say
if you've been around long enough anyway
the 670 or the Kepler cards launched at
$399 a $50 increase which a lot of
people rolled their eyes at back then
going what the hell why the $50 increase
uh
$552 in today's money that came out in
2012 the 770 came out at the same price
400 bucks at in 2013 but because of the
next year it inflates to
$544 970 came out remember the the uh 4
gigs means 4 gigs era hey it's been a
while right anyway the uh 970 3.5 GB
card was 329 a $70 drop which made made
people go yay but later it was like oh
it's cuz I up the memory but
that's $441 in today's money that was in
2014 in
2016 Pascal the Golden Era of Graphics
happened and the ti variance so moving
forward now I'm comparing TI pricing
because they didn't exist prior to that
the ti only existed in the 60 series
cards which was super odd but anyway the
1070 TI launched at 450 bucks you know
if this cost $450 today do you know what
a
different like video this would be now
yes inflation yes tariffs yes tsmc price
increases across the board over year on
year it's probably impossible for this
to ever exist at that price point again
but could you just imagine just wrap
your mind around that for a moment cuz
also to don't be naive and think that
the 5070 is going to be the 550 bucks or
whatever it's supposed to be I forget
the price uh Phil can put the actual
price on the screen that's $595 in
today's money in
2016 the RTX 270 TI came out at $499 I'd
still take this for 500 bucks right
$4.99 again that's about the upper limit
a lot of people would spend on a
graphics card um but anyway
$631 in today's money 2018 is when that
launched 370 TI the first card that's
actually on our charts $600 that was a
$100 increase gen on gen making it
$72 in today's money and that was in
2021 I don't need to explain to you what
happened in the 30 series and what was
going on in 2021 to know why the pricing
got so stupid also too that was the
first time Nvidia had switched Fabs they
went over to Samsung which uh they made
an okay card but Samsung really was
behind the the the eightball or behind
the curve on the performance that was
expected so Nvidia went back to tsmc
launching the 470 TI in 2023 at
$799 here's the crazy part enough
inflation has happened since 2023 that
we have a correction of
$833 that's more than this technically
cost in today's money but
again this launched today at
750 but realistically if we average out
the prices that we're seeing on micr
Center's website it's
$950 so I made this chart this is the
gamer satisfaction per USD or US dollar
per launch
year this is a troubling Trend as you
can see this is why I say that this is
nothing more than a rich person's Hobby
and that really sucks because if you if
you actually scroll around Reddit or any
other PC forums or
whatever there are an awful lot of
people saying it I'm just going to
get a PS5 Pro Pro and a monitor for
cheaper than what One graphics card
would cost PC
gaming and here's the real reason this
is happening nothing I say nothing Steve
says or his Apostles nothing lonus says
makes a difference we don't change
anything do you know why this is not
where Nvidia makes its money anymore
it's all Ai and all you need to look at
is just since 2010 when I showed you
these GPU price inflations and price
changes look at the stock and do you
know who Nvidia is interested in
appeasing it's those people who own that
stock so yes Nvidia took a big hit when
um deep seek came out but it rebounded
it's on the rebound and going back up
and I'm kind of kicking my ass that I
didn't buy it when it was down quite a
bit but that's also because I don't play
the stocks it's just way too volatile so
the 5070 TI in a nutshell 5070 TI it's
about as fast as a 4080 sometimes a 4080
super it costs 50 bucks less technically
than the 470 TI it's not going to be
available the real price is almost
$1,000 it's not worth it so anyway to to
re to to just sort of conclude
here I cannot I I just can't imagine I
guess I have to it's happening a 70
series card whether it's a TI or not
costing uh nearly $1,000 the ti models
used to be $50 to $100 more maybe like
if I had the non-ti versions on there
from Pascal forward you would see about
a $50 to $100 difference depending on
the model it's it's out of control it's
out of control Nvidia is not for the
gamer anymore they are for AI profit all
of this with AI is the house that
GeForce built GeForce enabled AI to
reach the masses and now ai is coming
home to
GeForce and uh these are the these are
just the bones that were being thrown so
I would also say hey 970 and 970 XT are
coming Nidia or AMD BSA but you know
what they've had so many opportunities
to be the hero in this but they're
they're a sheep they're following
nvidia's pathway they're not going
against the grain so I have no hope for
that either 507 is coming if Nvidia
decides to seed me but if they don't I
really don't give a